hi i'm david harbour i play the red
guardian hi i'm florence pugh and i play
elena belova hi i'm scarlett johansson
and i play
black widow natasha romanoff and today
we're with buzzfeed playing a game of
who's
who who's most likely to start laughing
and break character during a take one
david
florence maybe florence what
you know nobody wants to be that person
and i don't think you are florence
at all
i remember david doing some pretty
wheezy laughing
when he was trying to do his russian
drinking and then scarlett would start
laughing
and then kate would be heard laughing
outside right and then florence was
completely in character the whole yeah
yeah
i was crying like i was crying next one
before we eat each other alive who's
most likely to forget their lines
rachel oh rachel yeah yeah right though
why are you saying me dude i even
corrected your lines once
all right how about this i got my own
question who's most likely to make up
their lines
you yeah i did a little bit when we were
doing that 4 a.m night shoot
and i had to say loads of history and
jargon and i was so
out of it that i just started making up
history and then scarlett
had to wrap a bandage around my arm and
at 4am she went
god i'm finding it really hard which
thing to remember to do
first and i remember just turning to her
and going what did you just say
and she was like no it's just like i
don't know which thing goes first i was
like
i have to remember a whole page of
marvel history
i was like you put the band-aid instead
of the gauze
i have an older swiss cheese brain okay
you're fresh you're new
who's most likely to randomly burst out
into song scarlett
yeah scarlet scarlet and i would get
into jigs
like that who is most similar to their
black
widow character me
[Laughter]
i don't think anybody is that similar to
their character yeah i don't know if
we're similar but i do think when we
started shooting really sort of fell
into our role oh yeah
and that family dynamic of us
really started to emerge naturally
scarlett being the oldest
kind of daughter florence being the
younger baby
and me being the annoying father exactly
dad jokes annoying kind of needs to win
every
month kind and amazing and really strong
and beautiful
and the most cleverest that's how we
sort of fell
into it who's most likely to win a game
of marvel cinematic
universe trivia i think oh wait marvel
said oh no yeah not me
a humongous nerd i think i would do i'll
leave you all in the dust
who's most likely to nail a stunt on
their first take
all right three two one all right we're
supposed to do it at the same time
i'd say florence man well how about this
who's
least likely to nail a stunt on their
first take
me you're like athletic and stuff i like
sitting down on couches
you had like a massive suit and helmet
on
and like you know you had a little bit
more to deal with so did you scarlett
you had a suit that you couldn't move in
remember your backpack scarlett that you
couldn't actually
lift your arms in you had to take it off
to actually
talk and sit down and you're like yeah
but david you had a helmet
your head was like crushed in something
it was crushed inside
it didn't smell very good at the end of
the day i have to did enough who's most
likely to pull a prank
on set flooring yeah me
yeah me i agree i'm a bit of a joker
i just like teasing i did actually get
into a really nice habit of putting my
finger up
david's nose in really inconvenient
times and he really likes it
if i was there right now i i would think
yeah exactly
just like that scarlet and i always used
to put our fingers at each other's
armpits when they were sweaty
oh god that's disgusting no it was
really lovely it was like
you're really getting to know me like i
remember after one of our fight
sequences
it had been really hot and we were
wearing really not
breathable clothes and she put her arm
under my armpit and scarlet do you
remember you turned me and you went wow
that's a wet pit and it was within the
first week
of knowing her and i died it's not what
you want scarlett johansson to notice
on the first week of filming who's most
likely to be caught napping in between
scenes me i'm laughing too man wait
i'm very in how many naps do you take a
day on set
i would just go off to that tent between
every tape there wouldn't be even just a
table and i would just like go like
wake up come back do the scene you're a
big napper scarlett
yes i don't know why i napped so much at
work i think it just
there's so much waiting around time and
i i don't like to get engaged in
anything else that's meaningful
while i'm working so i think my i just
like shut down a nap who's the best
at doing impressions of other cast
members
florence i don't know i remember
copying the way that um david would walk
in his suit
being like full-on russian papa and i
used to copy that
but i'm not gonna do that right now
because david's gonna be watching with
hawkeye